hello in this video we'll talk about
nucleotide probes and its application in
molecular biology nucleotide probes are
rna or dna oligonucleotide sequences
that can be targeted against specific
dna or rna sequences and they can bind
via watson and creek base pairing so
there could be two types of probes dna
probes and rna probes in this video
we'll talk about
what are the application of nucleotide
probes how probes are generated and how
to design a pro before starting the
video we'll talk about little bit about
the applications of probe and later on
we would elaborate on that part
so stay tuned till the end of this video
nucleotide probes are used in techniques
like southern or northern hybridization
in situ hybridization etc at any point
you want to learn more about these
techniques you can click on the i button
other than that
probe based techniques are used in
forensic sciences and also in genomics
to detect
mutations genomic locus or let's say to
screen a genomic dna library
now let's understand how to generate a
probe or how to design a probe
so this is a mrna of interest that we
want to detect using a nucleotide probe
so first and foremost we need to have a
sequence information
that we want to detect
so the sequence information can be
obtained via several sequence
repositories such as ncbi embl or ddbj
once we get the sequence information we
need to understand how to generate a
specific probe
which would only bind to that sequence
and should not hybridize or recognize
other sequences so if this is an mrna
there are multiple segments of this mrna
such as 5 prime utr three prime utr or
several exons if we design probe against
these utrs or let's say exonexon
junctions chances are these probes would
be highly specific because exon to exon
junctions or 5 prime or 3 prime utrs are
very much specific to one particular
mrna and it should not be found in other
mrnas as well
so
this can gives a give us
nice sequence specificity
another thing to consider while
designing the probe is this length probe
should not be too short or too long both
of that can result in a non-specific
hybridization
now once we have the sequence
information in mind we know against whom
we need to design a probe we can extract
the rna we can make cdna by rt pcr and
then we can clone this cdna of interest
in a p blue script plasmid
which has promoters
for
t3 or t7
then we linearize the plasmid using
restriction endonuclease since we have
t3 t7 promoters we can use a t3 or t7
rna polymerase to do a in vitro
transcription reaction
while performing the in vitro
transcription reaction we can
give
specific nucleotides which are labeled
let's say they are fluorescently labeled
let's say they are biotinylated or let's
say they are radioactively labeled
and the mrna probe that would be
generated would be also labeled either
radio level or let's say fluorescently
labeled
and this is how we can generate a rna
probe now let's talk about how we can
generate a dna probe
but before that try to understand
that
in order to get a particular
probe we can
extract the tissue
we can extract the rna make cdna
and then
we can also
use a primer
which has
a t7 or t3 sequence
right instead of cloning it into the
vector we can also extract the rna from
a specific
location
then we can generate the cdna amplify
the cdna with a primer containing the t3
or t7
promoters that would also give us a
probe which is
specific and which is labeled now later
on the strategy is same we'll use t3 t3
or t7 rna polymerase to do a in vitro
transcription using labeled
nucleotides to label the rna probe so
these are two methods by which rna
probes can be generated
now let's talk about how fluorescently
labeled dna probes can be generated so
let's say this is a dns uh probe or a
portion of the dna that we can use as a
probe how do we label it there are
several ways to label it we can first do
a digestion with dnas one
and then
there would be several nicks in these
dna
and this
nix can be
recognized by dna poll one and dna poll
one would repair it and remove a portion
of this dna extend it
while extension if we provide
fluorescently level probes or let's say
radio level probes it would incorporate
in the dna and at the res as a result
we'll get a labeled dna and this can be
used as a dna probe
now let's talk about the application of
nucleotide probe in details
first and foremost we can understand
nucleotide probes can be used in
fluorescence in situ hybridization
to
determine in situ localization of a
particular mutation or locus of a
particular gene
etc so
fluorescence sensitive hybridization is
a frequently used tool in molecular
biology
if you want to learn more about it click
here in the i button
now fluorescence in situ hybridization
can
tell us about several aspects such as is
there a mutation if there is a mutation
what is the location of that particular
mutation on a chromosome it can also
give us information about the
subcellular localization of an mrna
inside a cell
other than that
we can use radio level probes or other
level probes in southern or northern
hybridization to detect a dna of
interest or rna of interest and in order
to learn more about southern or northern
hybridization click on the i button
now this is particularly important in
forensic application because rflp
technique can be used
using probes now let's say we have a
crime scene we can obtain the dna we can
digest the dna with restriction
fragments we can do the same for two
primes of suspects suspect one and two
and then we can do our northern
hybridized we can do a southern
hybridization
and the autoradiogram
would tell us that whose restriction
fragment lend polymorphism is kind of
matching the crime scene in this case
the suspect 2 is a match for the dna
obtained from the crime scene if you
want to learn more about rflp you can
click on the i button
now let me tell you that before the
discovery of pcr or high throughput
sequencing nucleotide based probes or
these kind of probe based techniques
were
key aspects in molecular biology
southern blot which was discovered in
1975 dna fingerprinting which was
discovered in 1984 all utilize these
probe based methods
now these days
we have high throughput sequencers
which can tell us the sequence of a
nucleotide region
in a blink of an eye
so in this particular era
we might think that
dna probes or rna probes are irrelevant
but still let me tell you in several
applications like fluorescence in situ
hybridization
fluorescently level probes are utilized
very frequently and fish is utilized to
detect or localize mutations
genetic counseling to determine sub
cellular localization of rna or even
speciesize identification very
frequently overall fish is used in
biomedical research or clinical
diagnosis
though
these probe based techniques are bit
irrelevant these days
still their application is done in
biomedical research and clinical
diagnosis
so
that kind of concludes our video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share share and
subscribe you can support my channel on
patreon if you want to connect via
social media this is my profile name you
can find me on facebook instagram
linkedin or let's say in twitter
and all the links are provided in the
description you can click on the link
and get in touch with me thanks for
listening see you in the next video
thank you